okay I'm gonna say two things and I'm
going to introduce to people and then
we'll be done it's not gonna be a long
thing the official body of Winston
Churchill is forty two thousand three
hundred pages long there are nine
thousand one hundred pages of narrative
history and there are thirty three
thousand two hundred pages of
documentary of documents those documents
are drawn from archives all over the
world a majority of them in some years a
very significant majority come from
Churchill's own archive in the keeping
of Churchill College Cambridge
it's a 3.1 million words long the
narrative volumes I'm sorry the document
volumes are twelve million words long
and the total work ham is there for 15
point 1 million words now first of all
that's obviously nuts
Martin Gilbert who was a very great man
for a reason I'll say used to complain
that they didn't sell more and I said do
you know anybody not like yourself the
work began the first letter connecting
Randolph Churchill to the Churchill
biography was written by Randolph to his
father in 1932 proposing himself to
begin writing an authorized biography of
Churchill at that moment and Churchill
made they commented you know I have a
couple of things still to do in 1960
Churchill wrote to brand off and said
this biography of Lord Darby that you've
written is very excellent I think you
should write my biography they talked
about it since 1932 they began work in
1962 Martin Gilbert was hired as an
early research assistant loved Randolph
and so now it's 57 years since active
work began on these crazy books I worked
on them from 1977 to 1980 and then
thereafter just about all the time until
martin gilbert died we we got on also it
was a kind of charming story that i met
the source of my happiness in his house
he he said we're getting a new lady
tomorrow and I said I wonder what we
were gonna do with her she's very smart
and the next morning she comes walking
up the stairs and I went wait that's not
the lady that's a girl how's that been
possible I'll thank some people literary
agents have been constant since when
Centurion himself was their client they
have a keen
idea about the value of getting even
difficult large things done over time
Churchill inspired loyalty from
important people never forget this
important fact
Churchill organized his papers and he
kept them almost nobody does that
he thought he was important when he was
a young man he also believed in writing
everything down
he told Clement Attlee who oddly enough
was Churchill's friend and admirer and
Churchill of Atlee although they were
bitter enemies on the chief questions
and politics it was a more civil time
back then and he told Clement Attlee he
said remember I have worked in writing
as you know because we have worked
together Churchill himself is important
Joseph's family has been loyal to him I
don't get the impression that they're
like the children must be of the Duke of
Westminster they're not rolling in dough
they're honourable they're honored and
they do pay honor I know a little bit
about the arrangements they have for the
revenues that come from everything
connected and they're generous and they
mostly go to carry on the authors are of
course important for a reason I'll state
of course people have supported the
biography of old and important ways
Wendy revs the wife of Churchill's
literary agent Lawrence Geller of the
International Churchill Society
Churchill Center I never get those names
right although I've been a member of
both of them for however long there are
many people in this room I won't mention
them but you know Hillsdale College has
been given some millions of dollars to
carry all this on and to carry it on
into the future too and without that we
couldn't do it
and I was asked one time how I find out
found all those people and I said I
didn't they found me because they were
interested in Churchill so that's
important and then the nature of the
work and the nature of the man just
before Randolph give his toast I'll say
what I think is the nature of the man
but I'll tell you the nature of the work
this is Churchill writing to Clement
Attlee in February 1946 these pieces in
my archive written at the moment in
under the impact of events with all
their imperfections and fallacies of
judgment so far better than anything
composed in subsequent years could ever
do they will show the trials we faced
and the situation when we made our
judgments in what we knew do you see
what Churchill's saying he's saying that
those papers are more important than his
own writings and more important than
Randolph Churchill and Martin Gilbert's
writings that's an interesting point
isn't it he thought that he thought that
he gave long lectures wants to sir
Warren Fisher the head of the British
civil service in 1925 explaining to him
how to organize the files and Warren
Fisher was a sniffing kind of guy said I
would think a minister of the crown
would have more important things to
think about and Churchill used his
phrase no longer civil no longer
servants with him in other words the
papers were alive to Churchill they were
the work product they were typed by Jane
portal faithfully smart had to be why
then have the biography at all well it
come to find out that this one is
justified on these grounds more than any
other
no it's justified because the
biographers thought first of all of
course they have an essential task they
give it the time and they developed the
knowledge to read what they say and
interpret them for others we can't all
do that but on the other hand
Randolph Churchill's principle his motto
for his books was he shall be his own
biographer that means I'm gonna take
what's written down here and I'm gonna
tell you about that and what I think
about it comes way later I learned from
Martin Gilbert we would interview people
and I learned the hierarchy the
hierarchy is something written at the
time by somebody who was a direct
observer especially if they're
intelligent that's evidence after that
recollections especially if they're
repeated you know and so they don't just
die I learned he would say no no don't
ask them like that if you go and say
tell me about Winston Churchill they
give you all their conclusions and that
means what they saw is filtered out and
so you don't say that you say where did
you meet Winston Churchill where were
you what did it look like I watch Martin
Gilbert do that it was incredibly
skillful and you know very important
people
Ian Jacob you know Jon Kovel they would
just come to life when he talked to them
first the details matter and they can't
be lost when they're summarised in this
day and age remember everything is an
interpretation of the past in light of
what we think today in our situation
their perspectives on the past and that
means the past doesn't exist Aristotle
and Thomas Aquinas both wrote this alone
is denied even to God to make what has
been
not to have been it's a violation of the
law of contradiction once it's happened
it's fixed now Reid Martin Gilbert I
believe that there is such a thing as
true history what happened in the past
is unalterable and definite to uncover
it or as much of it as possible the
story has several tools among them
chronology documentation memoirs and the
vast apparatus of scholarly work in
which others have delved and labored in
the same vineyard he was looking for a
reality if he wrote the word perhaps in
anything you wrote to him he would
circle it and draw a line out and say
perhaps not question mark can't do that
see so how is it possible it's it's
possible it is the biggest ever why did
that happen
part of the answer is in the attitude
and quality of the people who did it and
that means not just Martin Gilbert and
Randolph Churchill not just me not just
anybody it means everybody who helped
everybody who cared about it everybody
who preserves something in other words
it's been done for love but
intelligently by people who are skilled
thinking things through and trying to
preserve them I think that's a unique
thing and I'm proud to have been
involved in it especially as I'll say in
a minute because of the character of the
man their concerns
mr. Gilbert was born in Chicago grew up
in Idaho she spent 20 years in Canada
before moving to London to marry Martin
Gilbert I first heard her name from
Martin Gilbert I know both Martin's
previous wives and their splendid people
that I worked with one of them a lot
it's fair to say that Esther is the one
who made him happy why she's like him
I mean she's not as showy but she's
serious she knows what she's interested
in she's careful in probing for it she's
faithful and I know that because I know
a very long time I saw the
transformation in him when she would
come around he called me one day and
said when to bring a lady to the campus
and my reply was I'll be doing and he
said you'll like her and I said good and
I did
she's been faithful in serving Martin's
memory and keeping alive his work since
he passed away she was tremendous and
caring for him in his incapacity and I'm
proud to introduce to you Esther Gilbert
[Applause]
Thank You Larry
Thank You Hillsdale College our hosts
and the repository of Martin's library
and archive President to mrs. Arne my
lords ladies and gentlemen you will
forgive me for beginning with the
Churchill quote writing a book is an
adventure to begin with it is a toy and
an amusement then it becomes a mistress
then it becomes a master then it becomes
a tyrant the last phase is that just as
you are about to be reconciled to your
servitude you kill the monster and fling
him to the public
a book that is certainly well within
that description is the official
Churchill biography it took nearly 60
years to write and three generations of
scholars begun by Randolph Churchill who
wanted to write the biography in his
father's words
to have the story tell itself through
the words of those who lived it it fell
to Martin and Larry Arne to finish it
Martin who wrote six of the eight
volumes of narrative and edited twelve
volumes of documents and Larry Arne
to take it to the finish line by editing
a further six volumes of documents and
making it available in handsome bound
and eBook editions in the days when the
term to research meant to comb through
telephone books and search out and pour
through private and public archives and
letters to photocopy everything
available in the National Archives it
was a slow and meticulous task how many
of you have already checked Richard
langworth com to see if I got the
Churchill quote right in this day and
age of instant access we forget what
painstaking archaeological work
historical research can be and yet
though the methods of research have may
have changed completion of the great
biography holds untold riches to those
who seek it some in unlikely corners in
a hope to help researchers and and
genealogists I've been I've been able to
put the indexes of the electronic
editions of Martin's books on his
website in the case of the multi-volume
Churchill biography these indexes run
into hundreds of searchable pages
recently I received an email from a
Janice Harris in New Zealand who was
researching her great uncle Samuel house
house had been a chauffer for Churchill
during the wilderness years in the index
of volume 12 of the document volumes
Janice found the entry house
Churchill's chauffeur with 11 page
listings where Samuel house and his
cottage make an appearance I'm not sure
who was more thrilled
Janice Harris who had found her
great-uncle or I was that someone from
halfway around the world had used the
index on the website to learn a little
bit more about her family and where to
look for one index entry becomes not
just another line in history but a human
being whom Martin had included he added
in the footnote that house had been a
chauffeur from 1928 to 1935 and had
taught Churchill's children to drive and
was very much liked at Chartwell as she
was apparently unable to track down a
copy of the book in New Zealand I put
Janice in touch with Soren Geiger at
Hillsdale the biographers assistant
editor who managed to get a book to her
and to Natalie Adams who found more on
her uncle in the Churchill archives when
Martin took over writing the Churchill
biography after Randolph's death bill
Deakin Churchill's literary assistant
and the warden of Martins College st.
Anthony gave Martin some advice
Deakin told Martin that while he was
going through the papers he might well
find something that interested him
something that he might want to write
about someday it was not necessarily
what he could use
moment we all know the feeling of trying
to find something we've seen but we're
not sure where when it's 15 tons of
paper it's hard to go back
so Deacon told Martin to make a note of
it to photocopy it to take advantage of
the moment and the interest and make
note sadly I never met bill deacon he
must have had a fascinating life he was
a soldier a scholar and a gentleman but
no one took more notice of his advice
and took it as literally as Martin did
in this Martin collected everything and
his various secretaries and assistants
through the years struggled in vain to
keep up with the filing Martin's pen
like his mind was always busy he carried
a sheet or two of paper folded twice
lengthwise which fit into his jacket
pocket and whenever he thought of
anything he would write it down he
transcribed conversations experiences
people related to him what his latest
to-do list was and even what he'd eaten
if he was in diet mode one year Martin
and I were sitting with his accountant
who worried that the Inland Revenue
would question his rather hefty travel
expenses certainly some of it must have
been holiday he asked you don't
understand I said to him
Martin is always working whenever
wherever he is he will meet someone for
lunch for coffee for tea and take
unobtrusive notes of what they had
discussed at some point it may end up in
a book but those notes always ended up
in his archive wherever he was
Martin would seek out the places of
historical significance and described
not only what happened there but what he
had found there at that
he took maps he drew maps he took
photographs he took notes he prepared
for each journey and he carried around a
wad of papers which told the story of
what he knew to which he would add what
he learned while he was there in this
way his archive grew along with his
Church of work
Martin's archive contains hundreds of
boxes of Correspondence from the Great
and the good to whoever and whoever
wrote to him include including
correspondence with some of you
there are box files related to each of
his books which hold manuscripts
correspondence and historical materials
his box files of his letters to and from
Jews who were not allowed to leave the
Soviet Union included material relating
to the worldwide activism on their
behalf these 120 box files
Martin described as his most important
collection and certainly one dearest to
his heart the materials on the Holocaust
on British Mandate Palestine an Israeli
and Jewish history his materials on the
first and second world wars are all of
huge significance churchill ed martin
through the 20th century but the sheer
wealth of materials that martin gathered
together reflects what he saw as
important
following Randolph's intent Churchill
Martin told the Churchill story through
the words of those who knew him these
eyewitnesses gave perspective color and
flavor to what the archival documents
showed they added a human voice Martin
used this technique in all of his
writing thirty-two years ago when he
first published his main Holocaust
history he was criticized for using
survivor testimony
until that the Holocaust history focused
solely on German documentation of course
of course Martin used that material also
but in quoting what survivors had
witnessed and Diaries and descriptions
of what people had endured he gave them
a voice he made them individual and
human he cut through the vastness of the
numbers to tell us what it had been like
for one person and another and another
and another this is true for those who
had gone through the Holocaust and also
for the soldiers in the trenches on this
in the Somme and those who landed on
d-day those who fought and equally those
who made the decisions that govern
people's lives Martin traveled and he
spoke many of you will have heard him
people would come up to him afterwards
people who understood what he had
written about people whose stories had
been part of his last book or would
become part of the next one he
understood him he understood them and
they appreciated him he took notes one
jewel from the archive and I present
other jewels in my monthly newsletter on
Martin's website Martin wrote a book on
non-jews who had risked their lives to
save Jews during the Second World War
called the righteous among those
individuals he discovered and wrote
about were a group of British prisoners
of war who days before their liberation
came upon a young Jewish woman who had
escaped from a death march they hid her
in a barn they fed her they protected
her and saved her
Martin discovered this when he found the
testimony of the young woman in Yad
Vashem in Jerusalem in the book after
the book was published
Martin was speaking at a book launch in
New Jersey among those who came up to
him afterwards was a woman who said
to him I am Sara Rigler she had been the
one saved by the British POWs Martin's
subsequent correspondence with Sara
wriggler and her testimony is in one of
the five boxes of correspondence and
testimony of eyewitnesses and
documentation which are the basis of
that book as a result of Martin's
research and the publication of the
story
in 2013 the ten British former prisoners
of war were found and honored by the
British government for their heroism
Martin's papers collected and organized
comprised sixteen hundred and fifty box
files if the average box file holds a
ream of paper 500 sheets that's
approximately eight hundred and
twenty-five thousand sheets of paper but
that's only the a4 or the
eight-and-a-half by eleven inch sheets
there also are about 50 boxes of papers
that don't quite fit into box files it
brings new meaning to the term a ton of
work actually is probably closer to five
tons and of course that does not include
the 500 boxes of Martin's books his
source library and copies of his own
books every one of the footnotes in his
88 books comes from material either in
his archive or his source library all
have now been safely deposited at
Hillsdale College a shared labor of love
that will be an important source for
research on the 20th century for
generations to come
I'd like to close with an interview
Martin published in the Claremont Review
in 1983 Martin wrote AJP Taylor was one
of my tutors used to say that the story
of modern history has already been
written all the essentials are there in
the
three books that have been written
nothing that affects the main line of
the story can be learned from
unpublished documents but it was
remarkable or so it seemed to me Martin
writes how this history books missed or
distorted the main line of the story
while making fashionable clever asides I
gradually became convinced that the real
story of modern history had not been
fully told and determined to get the
facts and the story as the documents
revealed it
Martin continues Taylor once gave me
three pieces of advice to guide my
scholarship first do not waste my time
with maps this is not a serious
intellectual endeavor second there's
nothing new to be learned about
Churchill we already know everything
important there is to know third
unpublished documents can reveal nothing
new about modern history up to and
including World War two all has already
been revealed well I think we can all be
relieved that Martin did not heed that
advice
lucky for us he listened to Bill Deakin
and future researchers at Hillsdale
we'll also be grateful thank you
beautiful Esther thank you
hey JP teller was on the BBC one night
giving a lecture without notes he crowed
about it and I watched it Martin Gilbert
didn't and I came in the next day and he
said did you watch Alan Taylor last
night and I said I did he said how was
it I said well you know he foresaw all
these events 40 years after they
happened
and Martin Martin said what he always
said if you said anything even
ironically derogatory about somebody he
said now now I should introduce the
person who's been the ramrod of the
document volumes for the longest time
since we took them over and he's sitting
back there and his name is soren Geiger
stand up please
the graduate binos I thought he's about
to go to law school and I've always
found him annoying and wonderful to work
with Michael Dobbs is from Hartford sure
where do you go
Christ Church Oxford Fletcher School of
Law and Diplomacy at Tufts with three
degrees including a PhD in nuclear
defense studies he wrote for the Boston
Globe while he was a student he was an
advisor to Margaret Thatcher and thus
his career began to be tainted he's been
a chief of staff at the Conservative
Party I'm like well I'm going to quote
it I found in the in The Guardian that
they refer to him once it's
Westminster's baby-faced hitman
he's a maid bearing dimes oof Wiley
sudden you say that excuse me my lord
he writes books and they have historical
meaning and they're different from most
modern books of history in two respects
one is they call themselves fiction and
the other is they're not Andrew gets the
job he is a tremendous man and I thought
it would be nice if he said some words
tonight
[Applause]
Larry thank you for that that gracious
introduction but I have to correct you
on one thing you said earlier about the
job being done you know Winston the job
is never done
goes on and on and on but it's a great
honor to be here this evening thank you
so much for allowing me to have a few
moments to talk to you and thank you I
first of all want to thank all of those
who are responsible for arranging this
wonderful dinner this evening
I have eaten like a king I have drunk
like an emperor and that means I have a
full bladder which also means that even
if you fall asleep I won't as Larry has
kindly said I saw the right works of
fiction I make it up as I go along I
once wrote a book called house of cards
which a couple of years ago I had the
pleasure of talking to President Xi of
China about because apparently I didn't
know this house of cards is a very big
hit in China they seem to think that
it's a documentary
and I feel rather humbled to be here
this evening because you have had a very
intensive and I'm told and it's a superb
couple of weeks indulging yourself in
Winston Churchill which means you
probably know far more about him than
that I do but I shall stumble on
nevertheless and I think it's
appropriate that we should be having
this dinner you know in in in a month
which marks the 75th anniversary of
d-day I come from the House of Lords in
the House of Lords there is a what we
call a royal gallery which is dominated
by two extraordinary murals about the
Battle of Trafalgar and the Battle of
Waterloo by an Irishman called Daniel
Matisse it really is one of the finest
rooms in the country and if you ever get
a chance to see it please do so but when
you are there please look in the corner
not just at murals but in the corner you
will find a quiet corner there which has
a which has two books of the in honor of
the dead from the House of Lords who
died during two world wars and beside it
there are two extraordinary little
artifacts one is a chunk of oak about
this long which was taken from the jetty
at Dunkirk when we were kicked out of
Europe the end of the beginning if you
like and then along sided is another
little artifact which touches my heart
even more deeply it's a little box a
plain little wooden box which has five
little compartments and each compartment
holds the sand from one of the beaches
of d-day
when we went back the beginning of the
end and I think that it's entirely
appropriate that we as we are largely
American and British audience that we
should be commemorating that
extraordinary occasion which our fathers
and our grandfathers knew all too well I
have to say I think that it was a huge
mistake which we in this country made
not inviting President Trump to address
the UK Parliament sadly it was because
of the opposition of one man and one
small element but he came here not as
Donald Trump he came here as the
president of the United States of
America the greatest democracy on the
planet
[Applause]
and while we remembered last week all of
those brave young men who went up the
beaches not the cliffs of d-day the the
brave Britons the the poles even the
French civilians and actually I also
spent a moment thinking of those young
terrified Germans who died on that time
it's time to remember them too I also
remember that the majority of those
troops and the majority of those who
died on d-day were American we made a
terrible mistake in not being able to
recognize appropriately the president
when he came here but those celebrations
went off extraordinarily well and it was
a remarkable reminder of what free
countries together United can do and can
achieve it's not what divides us
that matters it what brings us together
and we have in common which is why we
keep coming back to Winston we can't we
simply can't escape that the job is
never done and it will never be done
because Winston will always be there is
the fountain of endless inspiration and
understanding on so many things still
today you know I've been thinking a lot
recently about the 1930s Winston's
terrible years and there are so many
comparisons between what was going on
then and what is happening now then as
now the democracies were under huge
pressure then as now pessimism seemed to
rule the world then as now the
establishment saw difficulties in every
opportunity and then as now the
establishment and the elite looked
askance and tried to suppress those who
like Winston thought they had a better
way of achieving things
Winston's often described by those who
don't understand is not per Tunis
he wasn't he was a
he was a pragmatist he was a pragmatist
who was wedded to the unquenchable
commitment to freedom to the ceaseless
endeavor to the idea that we make our
history it is not our history that makes
us and above all he was wedded to the
idea that he would never ever listen to
the manifesto of despair which is all
too frequent nowadays in the West that's
why he's still so relevant he's there to
inspire us he's a light through the fog
of confusion that seems to surround us
at times we aren't here to manage
decline we are here to climb the
mountain and yes there may be
difficulties there may be even dangers
on the way to the top but my goodness me
when you get there that view is
incomparable and it's what human
endeavor is all about looking for the
finest in us all not the worst he was a
man I think that who would have been
desperately grateful deeply grateful for
Larry and to Martin for what you have
achieved
you have helped create a platform a
foundation if you like on which others
can build and they will continue to
build for many years to come I know it's
been huge tall and it's probably been
filled with tears too but what a triumph
it has been as well and we really do
congratulate you I don't want to delay
you we've had a wonderful evening and we
have somebody far more important to
listen to in a moment but let us
celebrate this special moment and as we
offer our thanks to you Larry
let us
honor you your work Martin's work and we
wish you and Penny all the very best and
we mark this this wonderful occasion it
is not only a cause for celebration it
is also in remembering Winston and what
he was able to achieve even in those
difficult circumstances it is also a
cause for hope
so Larry thank you thank you thank you
in 1934 he wrote a chapter in Marlboro
his life sometimes I think his best book
it's called the deadlock in the West and
he's explaining how to think about this
war and he says you know there's a
little departure and he describes war
criticism and he says that intelligent
scribes will add up later about the
battle and if they went to the left they
say they should have gone to the right
and if they tried to pierce the center
they should have gone around but these
things he says don't mean anything it is
in the circumstances alone he uses that
expression the circumstances alone that
the truth about a choice is found in
1941 the Germans invaded the Greeks
they'd been the Italians before and now
it became serious
and Britain had a danger and I engage in
the same lots of humor and and Britain
had a treaty with them to go help them
but since the time the treaty was
founded now Britain is alone or whelmed
those are the circumstances Churchill
says it in the House of Commons he says
in their hour of need the Greeks
appealed to us for succor and by solemn
agreement we had pledged to help them we
could not say them nay to abandon an
ally in the face of the enemy
there are rules against that kind of
thing there's a recording of it it's
very rich there are rules he said you
see so circumstances only rules
Aristotle says that most of our men
weather is spent in making choices and
our character is formed by them and it's
always the combination of these pressing
circumstances and the right thing which
appears amidst them and the right thing
has to be done even unto death and
Aristotle says you can learn that from
experience and he says you can learn
that from example and he says that the
best example
are the public men who make the hardest
and women who make the hardest and most
visible choices in other words if you
want to learn how to live read The
Statesman who wrote the most and the
best and did the most there isn't any
question about who that is and I think
you're right Michael Michael we should
spend our lives meditating about things
like that it will make us better
Randolph Churchill is the great-grandson
and when I first met him I was
astonished he looks exactly like that as
his father before him he went to Harrow
as Churchill did he's been in the Navy
and served with distinction honor
he's a in financial world now he's a
working man he's a trustee of the
Memorial Trust for Churchill and many
other great things and above all what he
is is a oh he's a father of four
children married to Katherine and above
all what he is is a faithful heir to a
fabulous legacy no one better to end
this evening than Randolph Churchill
[Applause]
well what a fabulous and a happy
gathering we have this evening it has
been truly absolutely magnificent my
Lords ladies and gentlemen what a thrill
it is to be here and I can't tell you
how humbled I am to be able to do the
thank you that my great grandfather
can't do that my grandfather Randolph
can't do but in which we my cousin Celia
sounds thrilling to have you here this
evening my mother Minnie but also those
that worked for my great-grandfather
Jane Portal I can't tell you what a
thrill it is to have you with us this
evening and what you did for my great
grandfather thank you this dinner is a
magnificent celebration of the
finalizing of the great biography the
fact that their celebration sits
alongside the 75th anniversary of those
remarkable d-day landings which in my
view represent the most important
strategic Mint day in military history
makes this occasion even more special
the outcome of that operation without
any doubt determined the survival of the
freedoms and liberties we so cherish
today here we are this evening gathered
in the epicenter of all the places that
were so important to Churchill not only
in this remarkable Club but we have the
Admiralty just down the road we have the
War Office where Churchill famously took
to the balcony to greet the crowds we
have the cabinet wrong rooms where he
held 115 war cabinet meetings and we
have number 10 in which it played such
an important part of his life when
Churchill stood down as Prime Minister
in nine
fifty-five he invited the Queen and
Prince Philip for a final dinner and I
find it truly humbling today that they
still so many years on from that time a
providing remarkable service to our
nation it is well known that Churchill's
time at the Treasury was somewhat
challenging whilst there he said I wish
finance here's what Admirals or generals
I can sink them if necessary but when I
am talking to bankers and economists
after a while they begin to talk persian
and then they sink me instead nothing's
changed that i understand that many of
you have visited chapel today and at
Churchill's home our family is so
thrilled with the dedication help of
over 400 volunteers how the National
Trust has over the last 50 years cared
for my great grandparents home it is
more popular than ever and it is
wonderful to see that all the personal
reminiscence the family artifacts are
being brought to life a thrilling
project is bringing the visitors book to
life by digitizing it and the volunteers
have put their heart and soul into this
project it's something which will thrill
very many of you here but also engage
with the younger generation outside
clementines bedroom hung for many years
the original but now it's the copy of
what I think is one of the most
remarkable letters of friendship ever
written cast your mind back to the 27th
of January 1941 the United Kingdom under
Churchill's leadership has survived the
Battle of Britain and the Blitz and yet
the situation is precarious the Battle
of the Atlantic has not been won Europe
is dominated by Nazi Germany and the
Luftwaffe is bombing British cities
the Soviet Union is still bound to
Germany by the terms of the infamous
Molotov Ribbentrop pact and United
States is still neutral and has not yet
committed to lend-lease imagine then the
psychological effect of the delivery of
a certain letter to Churchill it had
been written by the hand of Franklin
Delano Roosevelt just seven days earlier
on the 20 20th of January in 1941 the
inauguration day of his unprecedent term
as third term as president of the United
States Roosevelt asked his opposing
political opponent Wendell Willkie to
deliver this letter by hand to Churchill
in London the letter reads as follows
dear Churchill Wendell Willkie will give
you this he is truly helping to keep
politics out over hair I think miss
verse applies to you people as it does
to us sale or no ship of state sale or
no Union strong and great humanity with
all its fears with all the hope of
future years is hanging breathlessly on
by fate as ever Franklin D Roosevelt
Winston even kept the handwritten
envelope done by the president for
Churchill and Britain standing alone
this extraordinary letter of friendship
reciting the Longfellow verse gave
Churchill real hope that in the heart of
your capital Roosevelt was going to turn
the tide of isolation and come to
support the old world this remarkable
letter encouraged Churchill to speak to
the American people in a rousing
broadcast in which he ended give us the
tools and we will finish the job I have
just had the privilege of returning from
Normandy
where it was deeply moving to meet the
brave veterans who are an extraordinary
link to that dark era their courage will
never be forgotten I would like to
repeat the words of President Ronald
Reagan when he visited Normandy on the
40th anniversary in 1984 he was speaking
at the top of the cliff of ponder Hawk
where so many Americans lost their lives
and Reagan said you all knew that some
things are worth dying for one's country
is worth dying for and democracy is
worth dying for because because it is
the most deeply honorable form of
government ever devised by man all of
you loved Liberty all of you are willing
to fight tyranny and you knew people of
your countries were behind you in the
modern world there are no more important
documents for freedom and liberty than
the British Magna Carta of 1215 and the
Declaration of Independence in 1776
Churchill deliberately licked them in
his last great multi-volume work the
history of the english-speaking peoples
it is strange to think that without the
birth of Jennie Jerome in Brooklyn New
York the shrines of our hard-earned
freedoms might have been trampled
underfoot by NAS ISM and that we might
be living in the abyss of a new Dark Age
all of you here tonight from Hillsdale
have played your part in helping us to
preserve it
it is truly uplifting that through your
dedication and support for completing
the great biography it will stand as one
of the greatest works of history
recording the truth faithfully and
without judgment started by my
grandfather and take it on so bravely by
martin gilbert
and his dedicated followers including
his wife Susan his widow lady Esther
Gilbert and finally Larry on and his
wife penny all of them have played your
part in preserving this history and on
behalf of our family I cannot thank you
all enough
the biography is used by those who seek
the truth and that sits very tightly
with the Hillsdale legacy and reputation
for upholding the Constitution and the
rule of law
Larry Richard langworth and your
dedicated supporters of Hillsdale we are
deeply indebted to you for finishing the
job there is still so much to be learned
from Churchill and this is now portrayed
by various mediums the film darkest hour
was simply extraordinary
with Gary Oldman and Christian Scott
Thomas portraying Churchland Clementine
then last year we were graced with the
PS the resistance it is only right and
proper that we salute one of your
fellows Andrew Roberts for his
Magisterial biography walking with
destiny Andrew is absolutely thrilling
and it has brought so many new people to
the Churchill world so once again on
behalf of our family I would like to
thank all of you for playing your part
in honoring my great-grandfather's
memory by completing the great biography
it is truly a monumental achievement in
our family it is no doubt on the scale
of building Blenheim
this biography will underpin Churchill
scholarship which will take his life and
legacy to future generations forevermore
in conclusion I would end my remarks
with a tribute that my great grandfather
gave I quote the words used by Churchill
at the unveiling of the Royal Navy
Memorial on Horse Guards just across the
road from here in April 25 he said we
are often tempted to ask ourselves what
we have been what we have gained by the
enormous sacrifice made by those to whom
this memorial has erected but this was
never the issue with those who marched
away no question of advantage presented
itself to their minds they only saw the
light shining clear on the path of duty
they never asked a question what shall
we gain they only ask the question where
lies are right it is thus that they
marched away forever
and I must say what's been achieved on
the biography by the Hillsdale team is
the most fantastic example of being
marched away with history so let us
honor the brave men and women that saved
our freedoms and particularly those that
serve our nation's so bravely today and
it's my great privilege now to propose a
toast to Hillsdale College for
completing the great biography and also
we'll raise a glass to smarten Gilbert
so I'm gonna grab my glass can I say to
Hillsdale College to Sir Martin Gilbert
and Tulare armed for completing the
great biography
thank you
[Applause]